la fiscal General del Perú Patricia
Benavides señala que existe muy graves
indicios una organización criminal en
que está en el gobierno y que Pedro
Castillo le estaría liderando la fiscal
general de este país basa esta acusación
en los tres graves delitos que son
organización criminal colusión agravada
y tráfico de influencias la tesis de la
fiscalía es que Pedro castillo y sus
colaboradores habrían manipulado
nombramientos de funcionarios del Estado
así como licitaciones para obtener
dinero que les permita a ellos solventar
otras acciones que venían haciendo
alrededor del poder que ejerce en este
país
Francisco hecha una vez esta denuncia
Entonces cuál es el procedimiento a
seguir que
continúa a partir de esta denuncia hecha
hoy en la fiscalía
Bueno ahora lo que le toca es al
congreso de Perú la fiscal ha hecho esta
denuncia constitucional El Congreso de
Perú tiene que definir Cuál es el
proceso que va a seguir Pero existe un
entrampamiento porque la Constitución
peruana Establece que el presidente en
ejercicio de funciones solamente puede
ser acusado por tradición a la patria
por impedir la realización de elecciones
presidenciales y también por cerrar el
parlamento pero este no es Ninguno de
los casos entonces lo que ha hecho la
fiscalía es someter a Pedro Castillo a
un nuevo proceso ante el parlamento el
parlamento va a tener que debatir y
justamente la fiscalía horas atrás había
señalado que existe una salida que Perú
junto a otros países firmó un acuerdo a
través de mecanismo de Naciones Unidas
en la lucha contra la corrupción para
que a través de este sea una salida y se
pueda ejercer este control hacia Pedro
Castillo Francisco rápidamente que ha
dicho el gobierno nacional y que ha
hecho específicamente el presidente
Castillo ya está denuncia
precisamente Santiago estamos en Palacio
de Gobierno esperando se había
programado un pronunciamiento de Pedro
Castillo a las 18 horas Lima Bogotá pero
todavía los periodistas estamos
esperando por lo pronto su abogado ha
señalado que este es un exceso de poder
de la fiscalía y que ellos van a
solicitar una tutela de derecho porque
según la defensa de Pedro Castillo se
estarían vulnerando los derechos del
jefe de estado